it's time to take that great idea you
have and turn it into a reality with
our buddies at squarespace they make it
easier than ever to launch your passion
project
if you want to showcase your work or if
you want to sell products of any kind
they have beautiful templates and the
ability to customize just about anything
so you can make a beautiful website all
by yourself and if you get stuck they
have 24
7 award-winning customer support to help
you out so head to squarespace.com
grace for a free trial and when you're
ready to launch use the offer code grace
to save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
domain
hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep i'm your host
grace helbig very very excited today to
have the one
the only the ever so oddly evie oddly
the winner of drag race season 11 is
with us today
we get to hear all about what it took to
get her
on the show after auditioning three
times how the denver drag scene has
changed
uh what she's been doing and quarantine
now that she finally has a chance to sit
down and reflect on her win
also you will be as excited i think as i
was to find out what she was watching in
her hotel room
in between filming drag race while they
were all sequestered and isolated
that really gave her the motivation to
get out there and [ __ ] [ __ ] up with the
other queens during her season
she is so insanely nice so sweet and
looks so gorgeous this episode so i'm
sure you won't be able to take your eyes
off of her if you're watching if you're
not watching
you should go to youtube and check it
out and watch we also talk about music
she's got a new album coming out okay
i gotta get through this intro so that
you guys can actually listen to this
episode enjoy not too deep with evie
oddly
[Music]
okay evie um you are a
so striking in every possible
avenue of being i have a
i'm curious about how you describe your
drag to someone that has never met you
or never seen you
oh that's a good question honestly
i um i try not to describe it to
somebody who hasn't met me or see me
because it's it's gonna be really
difficult i learned i
the best way to explain my drag is just
go to see
a show and observe whatever pattern
you see yeah and expect
something that's kind of the opposite of
that for me okay
yeah it seems like your drag is more of
a an experiential
kind of drag like you really have to see
it to believe it
in a way i mean you can you can expect a
few things you can expect
like some bendy body parts you can
expect uh probably
to hear or see something uncomfortable
but
i was just watching your clips from the
vegas review
uh and that you're walking around vegas
getting inspiration
and you're just kind of um giving your
ted talk on
that the fact that you find so much
comfort and making people uncomfortable
and i think that's so wonderful because
drag shows in and of themselves are you
know delightful and all of this but you
really push boundaries
but in a gentle way like you're not
ruining anyone's time
i mean that's that's ultimately the
thing is i don't what
my my goal is to make sure that anybody
who comes to see a show or is
interacting with
me has a good time it's just to be able
to do that
fully i have to be ready to make people
uncomfortable a little bit because
that's
that's really where we start to like
challenge like
the the way our world is built and it
helps us break down our barriers and
relate to one another
i agree i also think it's a really great
way to kind of force people to be
present
like making them uncomfortable forces
people to be in that moment with you
even if they're just like focusing on oh
my god why are why are they standing so
close why is she facing the back of the
elevator
like it's those little things that
forces somebody to actually
like you said be present and rooted in
that moment yeah well how have you
i mean you seem to thrive on live
audiences thrive on the performance of
it all
how has quarantine been uh
have you been getting your fix in that
way i mean
luckily um the internet is naturally
uncomfortable with anything
anyone does true very
true no honestly
well you've also been posting music
which has been
very very cool very fun you how do you
describe your music style
you're a rapper but it seems very
playful
um yeah i'm i mean i guess first and
foremost
i'm a rapper but i just
uh i don't i don't know it's kind of
hard to describe because i'm
just having fun with the experience of
making music in the first place so
i'll like take any specific subject that
i want to write about
and then just like have fun with words
i've always liked words in like a really
nerdy ass way
the thing is though i hated poetry
readings so
that makes sense well you have to make
it your own in that way which
is that must be a different side of your
brain
right because drag is so presentational
without words
you know and now you're getting to
exercise this more
wordy side is it like a different side
of your brain that you
tap into when you're writing a song
strangely enough
no because at least the way i've always
uh like made a number made performance
pieces for
drag is just trying to figure out like
what story i'm wanting to tell or just
hearing a story that already exists
within a song
and and trying to piece together other
songs or pop culture references to help
me tell
the ultimate story i want so it's
actually instead of being a different
part of my
brain it's more like an extension of it
because instead of having to like
search around for a different song to
tell whatever stories i want
i am put in a position where i get to
like
create the mood i want create the energy
i want and
force anybody who's following me to
listen to it
it's great well you've also directed
some of your music videos
and is that something that you enjoy
yeah i mean yes i am now
it's a lot of pressure to be a director
to like really make all the moving
parts come together i mean the thing is
uh
if anyone if if you've seen me on drag
race you know i'm not necessarily a
natural
p people person although
but i i do like ultimately having that
artistic
control of being able to see
an image in your head and try and make
that
come out in real life so it's it's just
been
it's even more drag instead of just like
transforming me i have to transform
an entire idea into something that
somebody's gonna actually sit through
hopefully oh
yeah well it's interesting that you say
that you're not a people person because
drag feels like it's very you know
interactive
in a way did you when you were younger
how did you how did you find drag
originally
i mean um
like halloween okay
halloween is just a good easy place to
start but
it's funny because drag taps in
and always has tapped into the one part
of me
that still isn't necessarily a people
person but i've always liked to be
an entertainer and i've liked i like
that control too of like being on a
stage and having
like an interaction of energy between
you
and an audience member even if that was
like just my mom and my family watching
me
like lip sync to destiny's child
well that's i mean okay i also
heard that you've auditioned for drag
race three times before
you got on the show so
in those three times take me through
what each time
what you did a little differently if
anything at all
um i mean it there's
a whole like obstacle course of things
that
already like naturally got better and
changed within my drag
in the course of those like three years
auditioning
but ultimately what it really
is is that i learned how to take
more control over presenting my drag
like i was already a fierce ass drag
queen i've been doing all
all the things i do now for like years
but
it doesn't mean anything if you can't
like sell that package especially
in the format of like speaking to
cameras that
was some place that watching my first
audition tape back
it's very uncomfortable because i'm like
hi i'm uvld
and i'm from denver and i'm in america
and i'm like learning that it has to go
further than there and that i wanted to
make sure i needed to create a story
from the beginning of my audition tape
to the end that would make the producers
if nothing else
at least look back and be like wow i
just saw something crazy let me look at
that again
and ultimately that's where it got to be
on the third time
that's very cool i also think that it's
really important
that you represent this you know
odd and strange type of performance
but knowing that you have to like hone
in on that not lose that
at all but just like have the confidence
to connect that weirdness directly to
someone else
because i'm sure people worry that if
they get on the show
they have to like sugarcoat their drag
or make themselves some
fit in some type of box that people
might expect them to do
i mean i can't i can't speak too
personally on that because i've
never actually been in any of the girls
heads as much as i've tried
but i i will say that from my
perspective in my experience it looks
like
especially now that there are more
seasons of drag race and it's something
that's more
easily available for people that you do
see a lot more people coming onto the
show
who are already like self-produced and
they're like
and this is how i'm going to act if i
win and this is what's going to happen
if it doesn't go my way
and like i don't know i a part of
what blew me away about the whole
experience of being on drag race is the
fact that i couldn't believe it was real
so i i was like i had no way to
sugarcoat
any of what i was feeling which
sometimes was not in my favor
but i think that that's what people
appreciate because
you i mean everyone that's been on this
show and we've had a couple queens on
the podcast that we've talked to
about this it seems impossible to
prepare no matter who you talk to
and how many experiences you hear about
yeah that you just have to kind of go
with all of your best tools in your
toolbox and then see what happens
shake the dice and hopefully steal the
crown
yeah how was do you still think about
the finale do you or is that kind of a
blur of a moment to you that you know
happened but
it's hard to remember no i still like
remember it vividly it's just like
everything else
along this journey like
like every now and then i will catch
myself like getting lost in the sauce of
like yes
i've always been here i've always been
america's next drag superstar
but it really like there are times where
it catches me by surprise and i'm like i
can't believe
that there are children around the world
who know me they can't believe there are
adults around the world
who like know me from my cross-dressing
i can't believe that i was able to
convince rupaul to put me on a tv show
i can't believe i was able to convince
her to force me to win
just rigged the whole thing in my favor
i didn't even have to try it
crazy what is
what's the pride like the who stops you
on the street the most
is there a certain type of person or
when people talk to you or come up to
you or notice you do they
say a certain thing um
i don't want to like pinpoint the kinds
of people who stop me on the street
necessarily
but they're always like you know the
weirdos
like they're like people just people who
are made to feel
outcasts like people in a world that
doesn't make them feel comfortable
in a specific place that doesn't make
them feel comfortable those are just
like the people
who um i guess my drag really
relates to help yeah
yeah i think that's beautiful i mean
especially because
drag in general feels like you know a
place for
oddballs and then to even go one step
further
and be like a true obama in an oddball
society
is like very cool i mean just don't say
that to any of the real weirdos out in
the community they'll be like oh
that bland ass pg basic [ __ ]
i'm so bored i want to see her shove a
fish up here
you're like yeah yeah i know the world
at least in drag is a lot crazier than i
am but
i was just i remember being like a
little twink growing up watching drag
race and being frustrated that
i specifically couldn't find any
representation for like
black queens who did the kind of drag i
did but
like queens in general who who like to
[ __ ] the system you know
yeah yeah yeah is that
um is that familiar to the denver scene
in general i don't know much about the
denver scene how do you describe
it um i
uh well how i would have described it on
drag race was like sparkly bodysuit
boring blah blah blah
but like i have to say in the like three
years since i first uttered those words
like talking [ __ ] about
um my hometown i have seen such
major growth here like this is the um
one of the only scenes i've
i've been to in my travels around the
world where there are new queer spaces
opening up where there's more inclusion
and representation in our drag
and it seems like a bunch of alternative
performers from everywhere moving so i
feel like denver's becoming a new alt
mecca for
drag very cool that's very exciting and
for you to be a part of that that's
really cool
um okay we're gonna take a quick break
when we get back
uh i have a bunch more questions for you
so we'll be right back more not too deep
[Music]
yeah let's talk about the driving drags
what are those like because i mean
one thing is you drag queens
in general feel like the most adaptable
type of humans that exist and then on
top of pandemic happening
the ability for everyone to adapt and
figure out how to hustle and and you
know get their gig
going is very cool to see and so these
drive-in drags have started
and what's that experience been like for
you oh my god
um a breath of fresh air
as much as much as i needed some like
time away from
the hubbub and some time to actually let
my body
heal from all the [ __ ] i put it
through uh
i've i really missed performing a lot
and
these like drive-in drag shows are kind
of cool because it just has this like
festival feel where people get to like
go and have their own parties in their
own car
of like an appropriate number of people
a safe distance away and i
i get to like exchange that energy again
that's very cool
have you had to change the way that you
perform on stage since it
is a little bit of like physical
distance between yourself and the
audience
um i mean luckily drive and drag is
as far as drag shows go it's like a
pretty big setup there's a big stage
there's lots of distance
and so i'm already used to performing
environments
like that for like big stages and big
rooms and stuff
however i will say that the idea of
doing like
smaller shows in a bar or something does
sadden me because my favorite part about
performing is that audience interaction
so i like to like
get in there yeah
well okay then talk to us about vegas
how was that performance i mean
audiences there
feel like you know it's a little bit of
everyone from all over the place
uh was that experience different better
worse um it's the worst thing i've ever
done
honestly i would love to hear about that
it was definitely difficult to get it um
up and running only because something
like this had never really been tackled
before
as far as like trying to merge the
worlds of drag
and live theater which already which has
been done
but to merge the worlds of like rupaul's
drag race drag
like and tell that story and
like still have our stories be there and
authentic on stage and like have us do
this whole like
theater world stuff where we have to do
rehearsals that drag queens don't do
and have them do stuff that they don't
have to deal with like
like like wiping off our bet back sweat
did you have to do any like real dance
classes or real performance
type of of things or were you kind of
like i have everything in my wheelhouse
i mean
i i feel pretty comfortable in my
ability to pick up anything
so i didn't i didn't do anything else to
prepare for vegas other than
like work on some fierce costumes
and focus down on all like the lines and
choreo
that uh jamal sims gave us anyways
because
he's a fierce ass choreographer so that
that was my dance class was learning
to do that choreography at all very cool
i also wonder about you've done so many
like
sit talking head interviews do you find
yourself
like speaking in real life in full
sentences repeating questions
and giving full answers uh
yeah but and this goes back to like even
my time filming on drag race i have a
bad time keeping it concise like i'm
just
like that that could have been like
three seconds long but no i appreciate
it i like all the in between
i also want to know who comes to mind
because i feel like all that
you know everyone talks to each other
give helps in different ways
collaborates on different projects with
each other
is there a drag queen that gives the
worst advice
i'm trying to think or is there a drag
queen that you just know you wouldn't go
to for advice
because it might be a little not good
um
no because i feel like i feel like
everyone does have some
strongholds somewhere and after a
certain amount of time
like being in the drag world you have
some unique perspective on something
that is going to be helpful
that being said i don't listen to
anybody else anyways
i've always been way too self
self-reliant
uh well speaking of costumes that you
were saying that you worked on before
vegas like
you've been able to pull very artistic
looks
that don't seem to like or don't have to
break
the bank you know like really making
something out of nothing
what part of your drag or that you would
give advice to other
drag queens do you think you should
invest your money in like what part
would you spend the most on
um
makeup probably because it's just it's
like costume making is cool you can do
whatever you want you can use hot glue
you can like spit and stick stuff
together you can use already been chewed
gum
yeah but really makeup because it is
another fine art like like acrylics and
watercolors and oil paints when you
spend your money
on good materials it like
really does make a difference so while i
can still do a mug
with like covergirl like you know
grab it from the cvs right before a show
i my favorite like change in my eight
years of doing drag has been able to
invest in a little bit nicer makeup
every now and then okay okay
you're still resourceful well to that
point
what's the first thing you do what's the
first step of your makeup removal
process because
you are known to do these very
complicated
beautiful looks and so that's a lot of
product that you're putting on your face
what do you how do you even begin to
remove any of it
um i don't i just kind of let it sit
into my skin
and then it becomes the foundation for
whatever my next look is
great it becomes primer wonderful no
no i use like oh i i have to do the
whole gamut
like especially because i'm always like
gluing [ __ ] to my skin
super gluing it so i just like yeah
coconut oil
makeup remover wipes more coconut oil
like moisturizer that apricot scrub that
everyone
wants to cancel in 2020 because they
don't know the struggles of growing
curly beard hair and painting your face
i don't know about this but good to know
saint ives is cancelled just so you know
but i still use it okay okay
learning learning learning
um what's uh have you had any sort of
like
makeup or product faux pas that have
turned out um
bad that you'd like to warn anyone about
um
experiment lots with your skin just
maybe uh
limit your experiments to like one or
two
at a time yeah like there was one time
on drag race
that we had to like get in and out of
drag like three times in one day
and after having used like three
different makeup removers on my skin
i broke out and like all over face rash
for a week
oh for a week a week cute
very cute oh that's so fun and
uh after day five i think i would have a
full panic attack about this being my
forever skin now
yeah yeah no i already did i was like
i'm in a drag competition
but i can't put any more makeup on my
face
it feels like it feels like a scene from
a [ __ ] movie that you just got like
bamboozled by the
cool kids they put [ __ ] in your makeup
oh girl
and i was already fighting with all the
girls so i was already like
you're ugly you're smelly you're smelly
and
ugly and now you can't put makeup on
your skin
because you're a troll
the thing that i would love as a viewer
to see more of is honestly like when you
guys
go home for the day and like are you
you're all in a hotel
i understand and or you're put up
somewhere in los
angeles do you have like access to the
internet are they keeping you
like away from all of that you don't
yeah you don't have
access to the internet you you do get tv
so it actually it was the first time in
my adult life that i like
really had time to watch tv and tv ended
up being like my best friend
there because we weren't allowed to talk
to any other hoes i couldn't see the sun
so i just like watched lots of naked and
afraid and just really
i was like if those people if these
pasty [ __ ] can be
out in the middle of africa like
fighting each other
and lions and [ __ ] i can survive these
13 or 14 however many catty [ __ ] i've
got this girl
oh it's amazing that that was your
inspiration
legit yeah i mean it is a huge social
experiment that they
dip you guys into because i don't think
that part gets recognized enough because
that
like the loneliness and the isolation
your mind's gonna wander to all
different
places good and bad for yourself oh
you're telling me i masturbated to every
single male figure
in my life and i am so ashamed
you gotta
[Laughter]
so you were saying that you traveled a
ton before you know all of this had
happened for gigs and that sort of thing
have there been a drag culture that
stood out to you
either in the us or abroad that you
hadn't experienced before
um or a drug scene
i mean it's all of it just getting to
see a scene bigger than
the little bubble of a city that i grew
up and being like this is the world and
yes i have to be the best in denver and
i hate that [ __ ]
or whatever like getting to see a
grander scheme
really just like shocked me i don't know
if i was
i still don't know if i'm ready for that
the world is a very very big place
it's crazy because you win drag race and
then you're kind of like whisked off
into this you know crazy lifestyle
did it feel like when has the quarantine
and the first time you've gotten to like
settle down and like take a break for a
second
it's funny you should mention that
because it just like sounds so sour to
be like
yes this quarantine is like the best
like me time i've ever
gotten but like i was i was already
like deep into touring when i found out
that i won drag race like they were i
i found out like midway through a tour i
was like oh sweet i guess i'm a crown
queen and they're like no no [ __ ] keep
moving you got [ __ ] to do
so like i i mean and it's not to be like
complaining that's the world
stay booked and blessed all of that god
like god bless or whatever but
i as i mentioned earlier i'm not that
much of a people person
and so like not only adjusting to being
a public figure and adjusting to being
famous but also
having to like comprehend and reconcile
uh the fact that i somehow
after like 25 years of not even knowing
what i wanted to be doing with my life
ended up like winning rupaul's drag race
and like achieving my life goals beyond
like what i thought was actually even
attainable for me yeah
and i never had time to process that
because it was always like a new night a
new meet and greet a new smile and you
like throw your body on the ground
yeah and this is the first time i've
been able to be like you know what
you are that [ __ ] you did that i mean i
know there's a new one now but congrats
you deserved it now work hard and make a
future that you want to see
that's incredible and yeah that must be
i mean
i give you all so much credit for the
mental
energy that gets put and thrown around
into all the different things that you
do and the
like you said lack of time just sit with
yourself and uh congratulate yourself
on something uh that even like you said
it feels like it shoved your purpose in
your face and awarded you for it
and it was like off you go don't even
think about it
i was like here's the rest of your life
you're going to do amazing things keep
doing
and here i am like trying to think about
like what is it that i want to be doing
like i don't know i never really got
past the whole get on drag race thing
and definitely never gotten to the
winning zone
but that's i mean i think it's yeah it's
forced everyone to kind of sit
with themselves and figure out what you
want to do and you
have made beautiful music you've made
beautiful looks like
i also think it's very cool that you
don't
uh you don't kind of shelter your voice
or cover
your voice on like political things and
like real world things
on your social media do you feel any
sense of pressure
to have to kind of be more conservative
about
speaking your opinions or do you feel
like
yeah yeah oh yeah well specifically
right now we live
in a time period that's this crazy shift
of energy
where i think some of the most
progressive people in the country are
also starting to become some of the most
stifling people
in the country because there's only
there's this weird mindset of you have
to fit into
the new list of rules of what it means
to be a progressive
forward thinking person today and if
you're not saying the words we say and
not not saying the words we don't say
if you're not going the places we go if
you don't believe all the things we do
and if you don't
hate every single person who is on our
death list
then you're a terrible republican racist
i don't know i so i do feel the pressure
of not
using my voice nearly as much um
especially seeing how some of my peers
operate in this world of like
yeah i'm just going to smile and i think
racism is bad i guess
i don't i don't care if it makes me the
least popular [ __ ] in history people
need to get over it because sometimes
if you award somebody a voice it's just
gonna be difficult for you to shut them
up
and we're in a great place for that now
because like the black lives matter
movement for example
is 10 years deep we've had that hashtag
for like a decade
and i will say that i've never felt like
we are
closer to actually changing the world
and
and attaining some sort of retribution
for all the wrongs that have been done
against
black people and people of color in
america in general
and it's just because people were so
vocal for such a long period of time
yeah i mean it's it's incredible when
you think about it and
that's the thing is that the pandemic
has caused all of us to
sit and think about it and uh yeah
to get some perspective going for
everyone
um but i'm glad that you still feel your
convictions and you still are doing
exactly what it is that you want to do
uh we're gonna take one last break when
we get back i have a bunch of questions
from uh people on instagram for you so
we'll be right back with more not too
deep
[Music]
hello listeners grace helbig here
wanting to say two things
a big thank you for listening to the
podcast
uh if you're a regular listener if this
is your first time listening welcome
and thank you and uh second thing if you
are enjoying yourself here in this not
too deep
world we've built and you'd like to
leave us a review that would be
so wonderful if you can go to the itunes
store the app store and leave us a
lovely little
review comment how are you feeling good
bad otherwise maybe just good
or otherwise would be appreciated other
than that enjoy the podcast
evie before we get into these questions
from instagram i'm gonna ask you
the two questions that i ask every
single guest
that is on the podcast and the first
question is who
alive or dead would you most want to
throw cold spaghetti at
oh who alive or dead would i want to
throw
cold spaghetti at hmm
i feel like my answer is probably
someone like divine because she she do
she looks like she'd
she'd enjoy the [ __ ] out of it
she'd go swimming she'd make love to the
cold spaghetti
yes she'd write a song about it
oh yeah she'd throw it up eat it herself
again
it'd be great um okay the other question
i ask every single guest is to tell us
your worst
pant [ __ ] story or some sort of like
bathroom
close call that you've experienced but
you can only use three words or small
phrases
so mine for example is college
jogging front lawn
yeah not fun mine is
um
winning blackout
trashcan
i feel like that's the name of a song
that you're about to write
that's pretty great it's on the new
album
uh okay we have some questions from
instagram for you someone wants to know
what is your favorite thing about your
style of drag
um my favorite thing about my style of
drag is that it doesn't
exist like people are like oh what's
your perspective
and i'm like i don't know i can maybe
answer that for
today like my favorite color today is
blue
today alone
i think that's fun that's really truly
um letting people expect the unexpected
from you
also it must be fun to create that way
just
sourcing inspiration from everywhere and
just throwing things at walls
until uh until they stay that's great
uh someone says you're given ten dollars
and you get to buy anything from a
bodega
what are you getting oh
ten dollars okay well right now i'm
really on this coconut water kick
because i like the fact that it tastes
like it's already been drank by somebody
and then spit back
up into your mouth so i'd probably get
some coconut water which i feel like in
a bodega would like
split away half of my money
so i'd probably have to use the other
half to
um i don't know like convince the clerk
to let me buy a pack of cigarettes i'll
give them a [ __ ] for the other half
of what that would cost
there you go a full show yeah exactly
someone's asking were the fights on drag
race legit or were they scripted
which ones
i mean i feel like everything has to be
very real because you guys are just like
pent up with each other
and no resources or outlets to anyone
else
that gives you comfort like they'd like
to believe that it's scripted
and i will say that the producers do
nudge they're like
somebody asked the other girl why her
makeup looks so bad today
but nobody forces any specific person to
do anything
so right i just chose to be
divisive
you're also coming off of watching all
that naked and afraid and then coming in
yeah they're worries they're all like oh
i can't stand you
i just chopped down a whole tree and i'm
running in like
i can't stand you i just played a whole
runway
now knowing that you were watching so
much naked and afraid
in between shooting the episodes i want
to go back and rewatch the season and
just spot
honestly it gives you some perspective
into exactly where my journey was at
100 yes um you've kind of answered this
but so many people are asking what
inspires you the most what's your main
source of inspiration for your drag but
it seems like
yeah it's your own experience in the
world
me my brain whatever pops into my head
like the things around me colors foods
feelings
moods all of it like inspiration it's
just this pool that we all
grab from and recycle back into do you
think somebody's creative and original
they're [ __ ] liar
i love it is there is there a celebrity
or a famous person that you'd most like
to do
drag makeup on
um i would probably choose like
wesley snipes only because he him
into wong fu was
absolutely everything for me like i
never knew i would like that
i never knew i needed it he was
absolutely amazing in that but his
makeup was so
unfortunate because they didn't know how
to do like beard correcting back then
and i want to give him the gift of a
full beautiful drag face
oh a second chance yeah i love that
someone says is there a color or a
pattern that you will never
wear or is everything fair game
everything is fair game
i i like doing things specifically
because i've never done them
hmm very cool uh someone's asking any
more music on the way
i got a full album dropping october 23rd
ah how does that feel now to be before
the album comes out
is all the music recorded and done
i was just listening to it this morning
shaking my ass
getting really nervous crying into a
mirror
is there is there a way to describe it
without not
without giving too much away for people
to get excited about it
um i i guess
yeah the same way i would i would
describe my drag it's all over the place
indescribable oh that's fun
it's something for all moods that's
great yeah
a lot of people are asking would you go
back for an all winter season
and if so who would you consider a
threat
oh i mean i would i would do it i i like
competing
i i like the idea of going back to that
competition now that i know what it
feels like to be in a competition of
that caliber
right um i don't think i do
very well so
not with that attitude no it's not even
that it's just that like i'm not blind
i'm aware of like the places where i
would need to like grow and show out to
make people really happy
and i don't want to buy sparkly dresses
so people can suck a bag of dicks
and i'm never going to be good at the
snatch game because i don't want to be
i feel like you and adore were very like
in line with each other uh kind of like
the same mentality of not
wanting to conform in that kind of
regard i mean but i feel like there are
ways
even then that like you can make it work
that's what i tried to prove in my whole
season
i just know that at an all-stars caliber
especially with the way that the last
few seasons have also been this like
weird
congeniality like both the [ __ ] off the
island game
oh there's no way i would last yeah
you're self-aware and that's what's so
charming
uh someone wants to know what other
creative projects or areas
have you wanted to pursue but haven't
had the opportunity to yet
if there are any would you ever make
your own uh makeup do you make your own
makeup
uh you know i mix i mix random permanent
markers with
random creams and powders sometimes but
no
i mean i i don't know i thought about it
i just don't really see what the point
is like unless i was
like god bless all of the people who are
out here like creating
new pallets with a new way to say the
color green
and like a whole new shade of nudes for
your eyes but i'd rather just use
other people's like if somebody wants to
walk up someday and be like hey would
you like your name on some makeup
i'll take it i'll take him for it are
there any other
kind of creative projects like um in
the theater realm or more in the music
realm would you ever make like a musical
that's okay so that's the thing is i've
i was a theater kid long before i was a
drag queen
and i would love like my first initial
gay dream was to move to broadway or
move to new york and perform on broadway
wow but right now just being a live
performer is not the tea
yeah yeah i think that's good
um okay someone's asking what would you
name
a hypothetical child um
i've had these names like picked out
since i was little i've had
ira uh august
and leo because i'm just like super
narcissistic
leo august me oh yeah
yeah it's all about me me you know what
i'm naming my kid me
i love that um
so many people are asking how are you
doing physically
um and like what are your tips or tricks
for
self-care well those people can mind
their damn business
um no i'm doing i'm i don't know i don't
it feels like yeah you seem like on the
show too to have a handle
on like your body obviously and you take
care of it when you need to take care of
it but also
like amazing on you that you really put
your body
out there every time like you give full
performances
i mean it's definitely super taxing and
i know it's
technically speaking not what i should
be doing with my body if i want to live
to
old age and like have nice happy like
whatever but i've never seen my life
going that way
i've never like seen that being some
opportunity for me
so i have just been kind of like
endlessly throwing my body on the ground
so it was it was like it was like pretty
messed up
after this like last year of literal
non-stop touring but
yeah now that we've had like a good half
a year of
unemployment and me only occasionally
popping out to do some cardio like
i can really a feel the damage b feel my
age but see
feel good in the fact that i don't feel
as compelled
to do the most every single time because
of it
that's good you're learning your
boundaries
ish we'll see what happens um okay last
question for you what's your favorite
trash food
are you a food person are you a foodie
are you
you are okay so what's your what's your
i guess guilty pleasure food or like
high falutin
food i mean
i eat like garbage in general but like
my
super guilty pleasure is popcorn i just
like sit there and eat it forever
i want it super buttery i want it stuck
in all of my teeth i wanted to like
cut up my mouth and just live in me yeah
so cute very cute
uh well evie before we wrap up
completely usually
when you know pre in the in the olden
days when we could all do this in person
uh we would give a gift to our guests um
but we're gonna do it digitally or
virtually
now we have a personalized fortune
cookie that i believe
melissa may have emailed to you if
you're able to
check that and read us your fortune it
says
you can do what drake can do but drake
can't do what you can do and that's what
makes the difference and don't you ever
forget
hell yeah evie this has been so lovely
thank you for making time and talking
with us
where can everyone find everything that
you're up to where can they get the new
album when it comes out or follow you on
social media if they don't already know
okay so if you're looking for me on
social eve
or media don't look for any eevee pages
because they're
all lies my my handle is always going to
be oddly
evie so that's o double d l
double y v i e oh yeah
very fun and then you can
check me out on youtube which is the
only place where i'm evie oddly
uh that's where i'll be posting all of
my music videos
like get ready for drag trap october
23rd
it's gonna be out wherever people um
sell music whatever street corners you
pirate [ __ ] from
love it yeah otherwise
i'll be i'll be in your city someday
someday fingers crossed fingers crossed
and uh if someone comes up to you wants
to put your name on a lipstick maybe
that'll happen too who knows
i'm ready evie thank you so much you
guys go get the music
go follow all the looks and um get
expect the unexpected we'll see you guys
next time on another episode of not too
deep goodbye
too deep too deep too deep not too deep
with christ
not too deep is a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer melissa d
montz edited by shireen laniunis
post-production sound by chris henry
and an extra special thanks to flula for
the theme music